Heil Hitler my name is Colonel Hans
Muller of the SS as you know we were
combing the area for shoes but it has
come to our attention that two Negroes
have escaped and are hiding out in this
area as well you wouldn't happen to know
anything about this no what you'll know
no Negroes here Negroes ooh no and
what's your name's Leroy hiber
leroyheimer is my last name and my first
name is very german and that is because
it is heinrich and so my name is
heinrich leroyheimer and I am Baron
Helmut schnitzel Nazi well are you going
to invite me in
please gentlemen sit down now as you
know the Negro not unlike the truth can
be a very tricky creature that's fun we
have developed many tests to determine
if an individual is in fact an actual
negro is very scientific
like when we throws beans up against the
homosexuals to see if the beans explode
yeah what kind of tests it's interesting
that you would ask me that would you
mind if I removed your hat so that I can
measure your head so Negro head
interestingly enough only comes in two
half sizes it's one of the many
interesting things about some Negro head
hmm everything seems in order
well no Negro heads here I'll tell you
what though if a Negro head came in here
it would find itself detached from his
knee bro this is very very good but
there are so many exceptions to the rule
which is why it's so important that we
have a test which is foolproof more
tests you know hunting the Negroes all
day you really build up an appetite you
know I'm saying can I interest you two
in some delicious beef the interesting
so Negro cannot resist the beat it is
wrong to it like flies to scheisse well
gentlemen it appears I have wasted your
time I'll be on my way just one more
thing I'm curious as to how you feel
about is
this cat's toy jiggledy jiggledy nothing
but that's embarrassing
I'm sorry for bothering you you two are
obviously not Negroes of course we're
not Negroes this is a no Negro zone
thank you gentlemen
oh that's new baron schnitzel Nazis
going on oh yeah I'll wait for you yeah
there we go
all right mmm by the way hmm
are you about transformation to the
dusseldorf needs some Nazis yes I am
how's your aunt Frieda
Oh Frieda she is still fat I don't
recall her being fat but who looks like
they did in college anyway I mean not me
not this one because I was
man that was close
we gotta get out of here man we left the
cat toy